What supplements do you recommend for kidneys? My urine, while fairly clear, is foamy?
Why wouldn't make recommendations for your kidneys based upon the look of your urine?
So urine can be foamy for multiple reasons. It can be foamy if a person is dehydrated,
that can cause a little bit of foamy urine. It can be foamy based upon your stream. If your stream is
quick, or if you're using a, if you're catheterized, it's very common to have foamy urine just because
of how it's emptied into the bag. If you have a strong stream, you can have foamy urine and there's
nothing wrong. This foamy, this of a urine is not diagnostic in itself. So I would say you don't
base your supplements based upon that side, you would base your supplements based upon other
things, whether it be a cheek swab tester, whether it be a blood test or toxicity test or whatever
other testing you're doing some objective data that's based, that you're basing your choice on.
So supplements that you'd recommend for the kidney, it's based upon what's going on with the
kidneys and the foaminess of your urine really isn't telling me anything. So you'd, you'd analyze
what's going on with your kidneys. You do that through different blood tests. You can tell what's
going on with your kidneys, creatine levels, your BUN levels can give you indication that there's
stress in the kidneys, symptoms like signs of kidney stones, CT scans, MRIs, things like that that
you're giving us data that you're having some kidney failure or slow functioning of the kidneys.
There's lots of different nutrients that could help with that. We would want to base it on that
data. So I wouldn't say, it may be you're not saying this, but let's say you're saying, oh my
urethus is fairly clear and foamy, what does that mean? Well it can mean nothing so we'd have
to get more data. So if you know you have kidney issues then we'd want to take that data and make
a decision on supplements. So there's a lot of different choices for this